So the FGFR3 mutation is enough to cause smaller bones, but,
would two alleles cause even smaller bones in the smaller person?
>> That's a really good question. It turns out that the effects of
a single allele are so significant that if you have two copies of
the homozygous dominant condition, it would
actually be lethal. Because it, the effects
would be so severe and cause even bigger defects in bone cells and elsewhere.
>> Do you mean lethal during prenatal development lethal?
>> Yeah. In the case of a chondroplasia, you can actually be
born as a homozygous dominant. But you don't live for very long after.
>> So all little people with achondroplasia are heterozygous for the
FGFR3 mutation. And that means if they mate with an individual of
average size who doesn't have the FGFR3 mutation, there's a 50%
chance that they, themselves will have a little person as a child.
>> And if they have children with somebody with the FGFR3 mutation,
they have a 25% chance of having a child with a homozygous
combination, which is lethal. Now that's a lot to think about. I'm curious
what you think you would do if you knew that there was
a 50% chance that you would have a little person as a child.
>> But, what if you knew that there was a 25% chance
that you would have a child that may die as an infant.